character design in terms of alien
spacecraft all that kind of stuff so
original and so great so great and and
creative I remember thinking after I
watched it a couple years ago that I
that I would never ever eat octopus or
squid again yeah but I had already
stopped eating octopus and squid before
that yeah remember that one time we ate
so with there's this restaurant on
Fairfax this is after women that wear us
don't we went to and we ordered octopus
and it was frozen it was like frozen
octopus no it was it it was on Fairfax I
think they're closed now
yeah they should be closed it was the
worst Rus don't we ever been do and all
when I ordered it he kind of went he the
waiter was like we have that yeah we'll
have the this octopus and he was like
what and he looked at the menu goes oh
yeah we do have that right which mean
that's a bad sign which means that they
have to go and find it no that's because
you you order you said can I have
octopus and in the menu it said bul bul
which is Spanish you should know what
[ __ ] boot boy is man you look it up
on Google yeah yeah but then when it
came it was frozen solid like they
didn't like you when they went into the
middle of it it was all ice they said ah
[ __ ] it
yeah man so it was really terrible what
do you think the guy his thought process
while he was preparing this dead frozen
octopus I you know it's like I love bad
service like very like there's this
restaurant called BCD BCD right there's
one itself we love we love there's one
server who would he gave us the plate he
threw it like a frisbee the tail it
splattered splattered all over the place
and then he just looked at her right
like
with really mean eyes you just say sorry
or nothing and just kind of walked away
and I started laughing because I'm like
that guy right there is gonna get a
really good tip yeah and so we Bobby
left him like a $50 tip not again
yeah I love you I always do that when
the service is really bad I always leave
really good tips so that the next time I
go in there that they're a little nicer
it doesn't work it doesn't work ever
just lose a lot of money okay because my
brother and I think drove by it we would
drive by it just to see if he's working
yeah yeah cuz we would look through the
window he's there there he is
you know we wouldn't eat there we were
so afraid of him we thought that he was
gonna take a knife and just like yeah
just collectively is just like stab us
as a family
there's another place of my brother and
I love really shitty so do we talk about
this the fish the fish cakes no oh yeah
the one in them all yeah yeah I already
talked about that before you can talk
about it again though yeah the food
court yeah there was this coffee shop in
a Korean mall and my brother and I you
know on the menu they had like these
they're not fish cakes what they are is
a dessert where it's like red bean and
then up and then they cook like up
reading around it right it's a dessert
but you can tell that they don't you
really use use it no one ever odors it
but my brother and I didn't know any
better so we were like yeah can we have
that and you can tell that they were
angry that we even ordered it and then
you can tell that they were like going
back and trying to find the batter and
near me and arguing back there like I
don't even work you know and then it
took them 30 minutes to even [ __ ]
make the [ __ ] and then when it came and
you can tell when they were making it
they were in a really bad mood and they
were like it was almost as if they're
like we don't ever want to make this
again what we should get to take this
off the menu and so we grabbed him my
brother I grabbed that we were laughing
we sat there we took a bite it was
unedible and him and I looked at each
other
let's order it again
[Laughter]
and so we paid the money and then you
can see the back there and then him and
I we just laughed laughed
yeah we just [ __ ] left the [ __ ]
place and we do that all the time we
there was a windy like in Koreatown
where we ordered a frosty and she just
was in a bad mood and so when she gave
it to us I just threw it away and I just
ordered it another one so I just love
because it's like [ __ ] do your job
yeah have joy do your [ __ ] job of joy
but it's not joy yes and I love making
people suffer when they're like being
rude just lessons baby that's not very
around dose of you radical acceptance
that's true but I want to go back to the
arrival though so you know this I'm just
Giuliana that's living with us she
hasn't seen any because she's from the
Philippines so she hasn't seen any of
the classes we're not [ __ ] sad just
back home